[Music]
hey
hello hello what's going on do you have
the package
all right all right have you opened it
yet no should i do that now wait one
second
dang it we've been waiting for this like
a week before we open the package let's
introduce who we are
i'm phil edwards common lounge this is
history club
where 50 of us know what we're talking
about where we roll ideas over in their
grave
you could tell the other guy ain't want
no damn catchphrase lmao
yeah i'm a bad liar okay so thank you
first of all to uh jose pedrino megan
long
and uh martin from vegas for these catch
phrases we'll never
speak of this again can i open this i
really want to open it can't open it yet
i just want to explain what we do here
on this show each time one of us tells
the story
and the other person has no idea what's
going to happen
and this time that's you you're the
person who has no idea um
and i just want to clarify based on the
comments from last time
got a lot of people saying uh what a
fake conversation all this is
no this is real the idea that we could
even try to act
is actually a compliment so thank you go
ahead it is time
open up the package okay
[Music]
oh it's a wig oh it's a raccoon hat are
we talking about david crockett
ding ding ding yes wow
i'm keeping this by the way this is a
gift
[Music]
i love it yeah thank you i feel like
that's definitely like just like
rat hair and asbestos
[Music]
in a lot of ways he was kind of the
first celebrity politician
uh and the way that he became this
legend and politician is really
complicated
so that's what we're going to talk about
today fine
[Applause]
born on a mountaintop in tennessee
that is from the disney movie and
television series about davy crockett
and he was like a baby boomer phenomenon
in the 1950s
i want to show you one picture too this
is a woman who was just making
all the [ __ ] skin caps well over a
hundred years after he died
these shows and movies they actually
changed the price of
raccoon pelts like the one that lady is
working on from
25 cents a pound to six dollars a pound
wow you know in 1960 john wayne played
him in the movie the alamo
and he was actually a really big
celebrity
when he was alive this play here is
reprinted
and it's the lion of the west the play
was so famous
while davey was alive and in congress
that he even went
on broadway and saw nimrod wildfire
playing
basically davy crockett in this show you
don't really think of people
gaining celebrity in that time period at
all that kind of opens up this question
of like
how did he get there how did that happen
how did he become this big celebrity
is that map on screen now yep so
tennessee is literally the edge of the
map
people did not think of him as much as a
southerner
as they thought of him as a westerner
he's way out there
i'm going to read a little from his
autobiography i'll just read you like a
little quote
at so advanced in age the age of 15 i
did not know the letter of the book
he didn't know how to read by the time
he was 15. he
tells a story in the book of how he ran
away from home
from 12 to 15 just because it was like
super fun yeah it's these political tall
tales
interspersed with how awesome he is at
hunting bears
david crockett is not just a hunter
and frontiersman he's this political guy
too
in 1825 he runs for the house of
representatives
uh but he loses the first time and then
in 1827 he runs again
and he wins so bear hunting raccoon
killing
david crockett is in congress
david's big issue is land rights for
the people who he represents so a lot of
the people that he represents
are squatters they find a patch of land
that nobody cares about
they develop it they maybe cut down some
trees or they build a house
and david wants to fight for them to
have the right to either
get that land or purchase it at a
reasonable price that's his big issue
he's in the house of representatives uh
but we're not at this like legend status
yet
and that is where my second prop comes
in should i put my hat back on or wait
yeah sure put your hat back on great
okay
now that you have your hat back on and
we'll reveal prop number two
uh which is this guy see
i was thinking about andrew jackson this
whole time also tennessee
celebrity politician folksy man of the
people
big personality yeah you're dead on man
you're dead on i mean
jackson is like the mario to david
crockett's luigi
david would hate to hear that can you
just tell me a little more about like
what you know about andrew jackson the
night he got elected he threw a huge
party at the white house and everyone
like notoriously just got
absolutely wasted and people were like
falling out of windows and just like
totally trashing the place
jackson is from middle tennessee which
is a little bit richer uh
so he's on a plantation and then
crockett
they're from this frontier they are
porter you know i should mention that
throughout his life there were periods
when david crockett owned
slaves too and so david does end up in
the house of representatives
uh while jackson's in the presidency so
david's big issue is that land bill
and jackson never helps him on it and
then they fall out at some point
a lot of historians point to the indian
removal act which is the trail of tears
so that's the forced removal of indian
populations
david crockett actually publicly opposed
that where's my prop
okay so right here paper money that
andrew jackson is on
he hated paper money
[Music]
he wanted people to be carrying around
gold and silver
the second bank of the united states
issued the paper money and so they were
gearing up to renew their charter
jackson did anything that he could to
take out the bank
including using the veto power more
aggressively than anybody else
i'll show you a classically awful uh
political cartoon
i was gonna ask if it has a ton of very
tiny illegible scribbling
all those people on the hydra they are
part of the coalition
that forms a party in the 1830s uh which
is the whigs
[Music]
and so jackson starts making this his
signature issue and that's where we come
back to davy crockett
at this point he hates andrew jackson
he's like
andrew jackson is a tyrant he's a bad
guy
suddenly andrew jackson has these
enemies
in the wigs so they are not the most
obvious allies to david crockett
at the same time they are the enemies of
his enemy
and so he becomes their friend
the wigs had this like superstar brand
to work with
i don't know if you remember that play
that i brought up in the beginning
who does this look like to you david
crockett this is actually
james hackett who is the actor who
played
nimrod wildfire in the play the lion of
the west
as far as we know like patient zero for
the coonskin cap is
this actor playing david crockett in a
play crockett
ends up making this alliance he ends up
turning into
a pawn in this central banking war over
the second bank of the united states
uh they might have wanted him to run for
president possibly they wanted david
crockett to just be
an attack dog i think he totally just
got suckered he got sweet talked by some
guys
that's what it sounds like to me hey
here have some whiskey dave like yeah
dave let me tell you what man you could
be president aj
sucks dave we can take him down together
my guy
i mean that we don't know that that's
what that's what i believe
no i think that sounds right i think
that's the simplest
explanation
[Music]
david's biography comes out in 1834
he starts leaning into the myth this is
a portrait
in 1834 of david crockett that he was
able to kind of art direct
he's wearing a buckskin outfit his hat
is meant to be a more man of the people
type hat
he even chose the types of dogs because
they were more homely
hunting dogs rather than the kind of
stately dogs that were typically in
portraits of the time
totally by all reports like the wigs are
the ones who push him to write his own
biography
and then after that they go even further
they actually sponsor
a book tour all around the northeast to
give speeches
against andrew jackson there are other
books that come out and they actually
ghostwrite some of those books davey's
rising up
with the wigs in tandem and then they
lose
[Music]
uh andrew jackson wins and when the bank
gets squashed
david crockett gets squashed too david
crockett loses his congressional seat
after that he runs away he goes out to
texas
and just a year after he's out of
congress in 1836
he's dead at the alamo executed after
being captured
oh good you're in the cap oh yeah no 100
it's really itchy
in 1956 those coonskin caps were selling
at 5 000 a day
actually yes why do you think he became
so famous like a century after he died
a lot of the pictures i'm going to show
in this video come from
davy crockett almanacs in the 1870s
there was a play by a guy named frank
mayo that was
all about davy crockett the myth
trickled along a little bit longer
and then walt disney is trying to figure
out
themes for this new park that he's
building
that's called disneyland he has
different worlds that he wants to
include in it
he's got tomorrowland and he also has
frontierland
and reportedly he just sends people to
the archives
and they come back with davy crockett
growing up i don't really know much
about davy crockett other than the
coonskin cap
and he's like an american frontiersman
and a cartoonishly
american icon i think it's so
interesting that we'll never know
what really motivated him you know
whether it was
such purity that made him cross over the
whigs
because he really believed that andrew
jackson was doing the wrong thing
or if he was just
playing this game to try to get ahead
and then why was he trying to get ahead
maybe it was to help his constituents
but
maybe it was still like have the sweet
life of being president
and we just don't know what's true about
his heroism
[Music]
there's more to david crockett's legacy
than just a hat
in 1841 david crockett's son
went to congress he got elected and he
went to congress on behalf of his late
father
and a version of the land bill finally
got passed
so he did accomplish something in the
legislature
in addition to making this permanent
imprint
on our culture
i was trying to think of how we can uh
involve the commenters on the next
episode and
i have uh i've made the decision that on
the next episode where i am the person
researching and writing it
i'm gonna ask the people in the comments
to choose the next continent
that i will pick a story from that is my
challenge to you pick the continent
that i'll draw the next story from for
my end of uh
history club
you